uh and thanks for the opportunity to
talk
and i also wanted to thank uh the
organizers
and the simon's institute and the people
at the simons institute for the amazing
job that you all do considering the
circumstances
i guess we all would have loved to be in
brooklyn in person but uh
nevertheless uh that is not possible
these days but
i'm i'm surprised how much uh i enjoy
uh being there virtually and
uh participating in so many things uh
that are going on uh so yeah thank you
to all of you
so what i'm going to talk about is uh
thin shell estimates for maximum effing
surface area
and i'm going to explain everything that
may not be so familiar to this community
so let's start um with the definition
of the main object we'll be talking
about so k will always be a convex body
in rm
then the classical um affine surface
area
uh is defined as follows so i'll
denote it like so it is i'll denote it
like so
uh with little uh f a s so f1 surface
area of k
is what so it is the integral over the
boundary of the connects body
k so boundary i'll be uh of the body rd
node like so and then what do we
integrate
we integrate the gauss curve with your
kappa raised to the power 1
over n plus 1 at a boundary point x and
we integrate
with respect to mu k the usual surface
area measure on the
on the boundary so what do i mean if i
say usual surface area measure i mean
that if this function kappa were not
there
the integral would just give us the
usual surface area
of a convex body so this is called
the f kind of surface area
and uh let me uh now uh
list or maybe let's look at some
examples first
so let me make sure that you see the
definition
so um let's look at the euclidean unit
ball
i'll denote that uh like so bn2
so that's the euclidean unit ball and uh
if we want to compute the f1 surface
area of the euclidean unit bar what
do we get well if we look at the
definition then we'll see
gauss curvature of the euclidean unit
ball is just a one
so we'll be integrating just over the
boundary of the euclidean unit ball
so what we'll get for the effing surface
area of the euclidean unit ball is just
the usual
surface area which is n times the volume
of the euclidean uniball
and um i always denote by this
with these two parallel bars these
absolute value signs
i denote the volume in in its dimension
so that's the n dimensional volume here
and that's the n minus one dimensional
volume
of the surface area of the body here so
that is the
one example where we can compute the
effing surface area that's the case of
the euclidean unit ball
the other example that's easy to see is
uh
when the body k is a polytropy
then um as the gauss curvature almost
everywhere on the boundary is zero this
affine surface area
of a polytope will always be zero
so those are the examples uh or two
examples
and uh that helps us to uh understand
some of the properties
so the first property i want to mention
is
upper semicontinuity so this alpha
surface area
is upper semicontinuous however
if we look at these examples that we
have up there we see that we cannot
expect to get continuity
because we know that every convex body
can be approximated
say in the host of metric by polytops
and uh in particular then also the
euclidean unit ball can be approximated
by polytops
but for polytops we always have affine
surface area is zero but the limiting
object
the euclidean unit ball has surface
area elephant surface area different
from zero so we cannot expect
continuity but upper semi-continuity
holes
now another um very nice and uh actually
uh
important uh property in the context of
this uh effing surface area is that we
have an affine isoparametric inequality
which says that look at all convex
bodies
with fixed volume then a fine surface
area is
maximized for ellipsoids
and i'll say that i'll formulate it a
little bit later
more formally but uh that's uh the
short of it uh there is this effing
isoparametric inequality and it's
extremely useful actually because
it lets us decide in many situations
where um ellipsoids are extremizers it
lets
us decide on the extremizers it lets us
uh uh it lets us solve extrema problems
when ellipsoids are extremizers
and uh lastly um i want to mention
uh that it is an affine invariant which
basically is indicated by the name
affine surface area
so it is an f1 invariant um let me
comment a little bit on that um
so if we look at the definition again
if we look at the definition again then
um
notice so i'm writing definition again
so f and surface area of k
it's the integral over the boundary of k
gauss curvature
to the power 1 over n plus 1 d mu k
it's this integral and if we look at
this expression there is
no reason to believe that that should be
an f fm invariant um
it's looks pretty uh uh yeah
it's why on earth should this be an
affine invariant
um and to explain that it is indeed an
if an invariant or how we can see better
that it is indeed an f and invariant
and also to explain a little bit the
name
i give another formulation of this
uh affine surface area which is uh
now completely geometric the one that we
had before
was actually my analytic via this
integral
but um well it was realized so by carson
shoot and myself
that actually this alpha surface area is
a variation of volume
that is it is you can look at it as a
derivative of volume
so how can we get this effect surface
area as a derivative of volume
so here on the left is our refined
surface area
so this we showed is equal to some
constant c
n which we know exactly what it is it
depends only on the dimension
of this expression here so we look at uh
at the derivative of volume namely the
difference of the volume of the body k
minus the volume of the floating body
so k delta is the floating body and i'll
explain in a moment what that is
and then we'll divide by delta to the 2
over n plus 1
and we showed that this limit exists as
delta goes to zero
and uh actually gives us this f1 surface
area
and so now we see why this quantity
is an affine invariant because it's the
differences of
volumes and volumes are of course fine
invariant
and also it explains the name affine
surface area because if we think of
minkowski's definition of volume
a this definition of of surface of the
usual surface area
sorry this is also a variation of volume
so that explains
uh the f and invariance and the name and
surface area okay
now um i need to explain what is the
floating body uh
or the convex floating body actually
there is another such notion of
floating body which is uh going back uh
to
uh the uh
like 200 years ago um of uh
a french uh uh mathematician by the name
of dupa
um he also had the notion of a floating
body but this one's more complicated i
mean you pass one
and not necessarily convex so we
want to deal with convex uh sets and
define the convex floating body which is
defined as follows
so um here uh we have our
convex body k and what do we look at
we look at hyperplanes h
that cut off a set of volume delta
of the body k so uh
the hyperplane h uh gives us two
uh half spaces h minus and eight plus
so we'll uh pick the hyperplane's h
so that the volume of h minus
intersected with k
is smaller equal than delta and then
we'll take the
intersection h plus of all the opposite
half spaces and if we do that the
intersection of all those half spaces h
plus for every possible position of a
hyperplane h
we'll get a convex body that sits
in k and that we call the floating body
so it's floating body is always a subset
of the original body and
uh its convex because its intersectional
arbitrary intersection of convex sets of
course we have to pick delta
sufficiently small
uh that like it shouldn't be bigger than
say half the volume otherwise we would
get the empty set
so we want to take delta such that
we can expect that things make sense
good so um
that's uh giving us a little bit of
better insight on this affine service
area but i want to mention one more
thing
and to explain why uh
this quantity is important and why we
really want to understand it better
i've given one reason already which were
this effing isoparametric inequality
which as i said is a
great tool to decide uh on extreme
problems if the extremizers are
ellipsoids there is
another situation that i want to mention
where this effing surface area plays
a role and that is in approximation of
convex bodies by polytops
so let me explain the setup the setup is
as follows uh
so we um want to
uh so we have a convex body k
now what we'll do is we choose at random
capital n points on the boundary of k so
we choose those points here
on the boundary of k with respect to a
probability measure which i call p
f so what's p f it's just the surface
measure
hit by a function f that's positive and
yeah so hit by a positive function f and
we'll you'll
we want a probability measure then
uh having chosen these capital n points
on the boundary with respect to this
measure
we'll take the convex hull of this
capital n chosen
points and that gives us a polytop or a
random polito
and one of the questions one of the
natural questions that one asks in this
context
is what is the expected volume of such a
random quality
so uh i'll uh we'll look at this
question
uh and actually we'll uh look at an
equivalent formulation of the question
which is okay what is the volume defect
between
uh the volume of the body and the
expected volume of
such a random polytope and that is
as follows so
here we'll have this volume defect
between the volume of the body k
and the expected volume of a random poly
top
p where we have chosen capital n points
on the boundary of
f of k with respect to this
uh probability measure pf and
now we have picked the right f and i'll
explain a little bit what i mean by this
so we look at this volume difference
which is the same as you know
deciding what's the expected volume of
such a random polito
and then if we divide by this quantity
here that is the number of chosen points
to the power minus
2 over n minus 1 and we let the number
of chosen points go to infinity
then we can show that this limit exists
and is equal to ah now i have called the
constant in the same way as i did in the
previous theorem it's not the same
constant
but we know exactly what the constant is
and um
it's just depending on n so you'll get a
constant that's depending on n
times this affine surface area raised to
the power
um n plus one over n minus one so
it's this effing surface area that comes
in
naturally in approximation of convex
bodies by polytops
um and uh in fact if we think about it
this is not so surprising that um
this effing surface area should play a
role in such situations
because what this f1 surface area does
in a sense
it measures the boundary behavior of a
condex body
and if we think about approximation then
intuitively it's clear where the
boundary of the body is flat
to get the same good approximation in
the symmetric difference metric which is
the one that we are using here
we should put fewer points where the
body is flat
to get the same good approximation and
we should put
more points where the body is very
curved to get the same
good approximation in the symmetric
difference matrix so it's kind of
not too surprising that this effing
surface area
comes in in such approximation questions
as it's
closely related to the boundary
structure of a convex body
now there is one
amazing thing that i want to mention
about this result
that i've mentioned here which is
um which is the following this random
approximation here
is almost as good as best approximation
so what do i mean by that i mean if
instead of looking at the volume
difference
of k and that is the volume of the body
and uh such uh expected volume of a
random polytope
if we replace this by the volume of the
of a best approximating polytop so i
replace this by the volume of a
best approximating polytube with n
vertices
chosen also oh not chosen they are not
chosen so
uh if i replace it by the best
approximating polytop
with n vertices i look at exactly the
same limit
with exactly the same number here then
one can show that this limit also exists
and gives another constant
say dn and again the f1 surface area
with the same power n plus 1 over n
minus 1. so the only difference between
this
random approximation result and the best
approximation result
is in this constant and of course
because you have best approximation
the constant well let's call it dn the
one that comes from the best
approximation
dn is of course smaller equal than cn
but actually surprisingly not by much
only by one plus
log n or sorry
only by
log n over n
d n so in particular as the dimension is
large
uh we see that that quantity is really
small
so uh then even in these constants that
depend only on the dimension
uh this best approximation and random
approximation do really not
differ by much
okay so that was um to give you a bit of
an idea why
uh one uh really wants to look at this
quantity uh
this airfine surface area and um
and let's now move towards uh um
what we want to discuss a little bit uh
uh in more detail uh in
in what will follow
what is the f you told us you're going
to tell us what the right
choice of the function f of the density
oh okay so
yes what's the right choice of the
function f yes um that's the
uh of course good so the right hand uh
choice of the function f
is if you do what i tried to explain um
what i tried to explain if you choose
the points according to curvature
so so the function f would be connected
to the gauss curvature of a boundary
point
i see so like if there is more curvature
you sample more points so it will be
like universities
got it thank you but basically we have
the result for any function f
that is uh positive and uh yeah has some
continuity properties strictly positive
and some continuity properties
and uh yes that was i i was always also
hoping that
um you know there are so many people
that are uh
in brooklyn now with so much knowledge
about uh
things in algorithm and computer science
so i had been hoping that
maybe one can you know even develop kind
of an algorithm
for such approximation problems um with
uh
a choice of a function and
uh that would also you know give us a
way maybe to compute
this f and surface area in more cases of
convex bodies because it's really
notoriously difficult to compute because
curvature is not an easy expression
to handle for a general convex body yeah
but um okay yes so thanks for the
question
um so now um
what um what what do we want to talk
about
or what do i want to tell you about uh
after you know just
you know explaining why this fn surface
area is interesting or
trying to explain why this affine
surface area is interesting
it's we want to deal with this issue of
upper semi-continuity
we already saw it cannot be continuous
this affine surface area but it is upper
semi-continuous
and actually then
would it be possible is it the question
that we get a continuous fun
invariant that is something that still
has all the nice properties as the
airfine surface area
but is not just upper semi-continuous
but in fact
continuous and this we can do
by defining uh what is called
the uh maximal affine surface area
so i'll denote this maximal affine
surface area
like so so i'll just use capital letters
as instead of the small letters
um so how is it defined it's
the soup overall
little surface area of c where we look
at all convex body c that
are contained in k and one can show that
the soup is actually a max and it is
attained
so it's maximum over convex body scene k
of f and surface area the left hand
surface area of c
and it is attained for um one can show
that it is attained at a convex body uh
sometimes i call it k0 sometimes i call
it
c0 so by continuity and
not continuity but upper semi-continuity
and compactness
this soup or this maximum is attained at
a given
at a specific body k0
um and then having defined this maximal
alpha and surface area one can actually
show
that this is continuous um i i don't
want to
this is pretty easy to see and i do not
want to uh
twirl on that too much but it is
continuous
let's look at um add an example now uh
what we can expect um now
for instance in the case of polytox and
as polytops
uh as a polytop let's take the uh l
infinity uniball
so uh so l infinity unit ball
is just um uh
um here is zero it's just the n
cube um with uh side length two
centered um at zero and
if we now compute this maximal f and
surface area
for this l infinity unit ball then we
see okay we do
find uh the euclidean unit ball in there
so for sure we know that this maximal
surface area of the infinity unit ball
is bigger equal than the effing surface
area of the euclidean unit
ball which is n times the volume of the
euclidean unit ball
and it's actually equal to that so for
sure
it's not zero as it was before
when we just were looking at the usual
um affine surface area
so now for polytops the um maximum fm
surface area
is actually also positive
okay um
let me tell you a little bit what is
known about this maximal effects office
area
and um surprisingly
the only things that are known are
things um
that the [ __ ] the only things known are
for convex bodies in the plane
um so the first result i want to mention
is a theorem due to bhagani and versic
in the case of the square in the plane
and
due to bahrani for general
convex body k in the plane
what this result says is that okay we
already know
that uh from what i mentioned
previously that there is a connex for
dc0
in a given convex for decay for which
this maximal effend surface area is
attained
so i've now called this body zero so
this is the body where the maximum
efficient surface area is attained
and what this theorem of bahrainian
version or bahrani says
is that this body z0 is unique
this result is only known in the plane
and we do not know if this is true in
dimension 3 or higher
the next one i want to mention
is again
a results due to bagani and versic for
the
square and due to bahrani in the
case of a general convex body again only
in the plane
before i can do that i need to introduce
some rotation
so we look at k a convex body in the
plane
and then by this script uh p
sub n of k i denote the set of all
convex
polygons that are contained in k
where we pick the vertices from the
lattice
c squared over n where n is a natural
number
so i have a picture here
looks like so
here is our lattice grid here is our
convex body
k in the plane we'll pick
points on the lattice
inside the body k we'll take the convex
half
and we'll get a lattice polygon then
there was a question by welshik which uh
who asked well is there a limit shape
amongst those convex polygons contained
in k
that are picked from the lattice and um
the uh what's meant by limit shape is
explained in the theorem that i
mentioned
next so um it's again due to bahrani as
i said and versic in the case of the
square and barrani for a general convex
body k
in the plane so what does it say and
it says that um okay
that the limit as the legislate gets
finer and finer that
is as uh capital n goes to infinity so
lattice grid gets finer and finer
of this quantity here the limit of
this quantity here exists and it's equal
to one so what do we have in the bottom
we'll have a nice slight use of
abuse of notation because this noun of
course doesn't denote volume
it just denotes cardinality so this
means
uh here we look at the cardinality of
all
lattice polygons uh that are contained
in k
that's what's uh uh on the bottom here
and on top here
we look at uh the number of um
lattice polygons um in k
uh where the vertices are picked from
our lattice grid
uh that are epsilon close in host of
distance
to this set zero that has maximum surf
affine surface area
contained in k and what the theorem says
that
as the grid gets finer and finer
um almost
all let's formulate it like so almost
all lattice polygons
are epsilon close to this
maximal alpha surface area set inside
the body k and that's what's meant by
limit shape so in this sense c0
is the limit shape of these lattice
polygons and
as the um lattice grid gets finer and
finer
and um and again that's a result that's
a very pretty result very beautiful
result
in the plane and we do not know if such
a thing holds in higher dimensions
um and that's basically so that's
basically all that is known
about this maximal effing surface area
um
the things that are known are basically
happening in the plane and so we were
curious if we could say
or what we could say possibly uh in
higher dimensions
and uh if it were possible
to say something at least um
on the size of this set uh this maximum
efficient surface area now for a convex
body k
in rn so that was what we were starting
to look at
and um i need before i can formulate
what we got
i need to introduce again some rotation
and
but that should be uh for me that now
should be familiar to everybody uh
in this community so um
so uh what's the notation that i'll be
using
so from now on we'll be we'll always be
uh looking at the convex body
k that has very central center of
gravity or centroid at zero
we can do this because the quantities
that we look at
are all f and invariant so it doesn't
matter where i position the body in
space so we can assume
without loss of generality that the very
center is at zero
um i'll also be needing the isotropic
constant
lk um
[Music]
i don't think i need to explain what
that is everybody is
familiar with this so by lk i already
know the isotropy constant
and of course we all know that um it's
an open uh uh important open problem in
context geometry and
many other areas if it's really a
constant
and the best known result so far um is
due to boast
so i i don't need to go into details
here
um now let's uh let's say
let let's look at the result that uh uh
we could show um uh now for a context
for decay in dimension uh
n that is k is a context for the nrm
what we can say about the size of this
maximum efficient surface area and
that's uh one of the results we have
that
i want to
so what does it say
um here
we
it says that okay so let's look at
what's what's the portion that we are
looking at here so it says maximum a
fine surface area
uh is anyone else having problems with
the audio
yeah i do yeah maybe too i assumed it
was on my end because i usually have
problems
uh elizabeth i i think it's uh the audio
is coming in and out
oh um okay what can we do
um do you uh
is there a way to move closer to your
wireless router or
um actually right now
right now it's okay so maybe maybe try
again okay yeah i'll try it it might
also help just to turn off your video
see you again it might help if you turn
off your video actually
oh oh okay
now i did something not good
so actually i can turn off your video
and then maybe we try if the audio
improves
now it's gone it should be gone right
uh it's okay for now yeah go ahead um
okay
uh is it okay now
i think it's okay for now yeah sorry
about that sorry for the interruption
no that's fine that's fine yeah um
and please let me know again um if there
is a problem then i try to get closer to
the
uh to the router
yeah so you you guys let me know when
there is a problem again right
yeah we will thanks okay thanks thanks
okay so
so we look at this quotient here um
it's bounded from above by one bounded
from below
by uh okay the uh isotropic constant
comes in
it gets raised to the power two n over n
plus one if we believe that is a
constant
then we would just have a constant here
c is an absolute constant
and then we still have a dimension
dependence on
on the lower bound so n to the five over
six which is uh
a bit uh yeah not uh what uh
probably should be there so there should
be probably something else there
but that's uh where we are at the moment
and uh and let's have a closer look at
this quotient here
um which um actually
uh so to really understand what's what's
the order of magnitude what we are
looking at here
so um we have n
2 times the volume of the euclidean unit
ball raised to this power
this is of course of the order of a
constant because euclidean unit power
raised to the power 2 over n plus 1
this is just 1 over n modulo constant so
that expression here is just a constant
so it says that the expression that we
are looking at here basically behaves
like
a power of volume okay
so basically what this says is that this
maxima affine surface area behaves like
a power
volume namely volume to the n minus one
over n plus one
modulo this lower bound where we still
have the um
isotropic constant around and this
factor of
n to the five over six
so so that's basically what we want to
get out of this estimate or
to understand what's the order of
magnitude of this uh
of this estimate and now let's look a
little bit at
how what we can prove this inequality
um the right hand side so that's the
inequality
the right hand side of the inequality is
actually sharp
and its uh equality is attained if and
only
if k is an ellipsoid so i have written
here uh it's attained for instance for
the ball but equality holds
even only his case and ellipsoid um
and i can give a very quick proof
of the right hand side of the inequality
that's the easy direction and that just
follows from what i told you earlier
uh the affine isoparametric inequality
and i now give a formal
um a statement of the if an
isoparametric inequality
so what does it say it says the effing
surface area it's the little elephant
surface area here
the elephant surface area of a convex
body k
is smaller equal than the f and surface
area of the euclidean unit ball
times the volume of k divided by the
volume of the euclidean unit ball and
we raise everybody here to the power n
minus 1 over n plus 1
with equality if and only if k is an
ellipsoid
this is the f1 isoparametric inequality
and by the way
for this maximal affine surface area we
have the same
f1 isoparametric inequality holding
now this gives us
immediately the upper bound because what
do we have to show maybe i'll
stop here uh maybe you guys want to
see yes let's see the inequality so here
we
have the maximal affine surface area
that we are looking at now which by
definition
is the little f and surface area or
convex body c contained in k
now to this little a s of c we apply the
above affine iso parametric inequality
so we'll get that this is smaller equal
nothing has changed with the maximum
over c but then
we use the inequality so we'll get f and
surface area of the euclidean uniball
times volume of c
divided by volume of the euclidean unit
power raised to the power n minus 1 over
n plus 1
and then we
estimate simply the volume of c by the
volume of k
and we
remember now in the
next step that uh the
affine surface area of the euclidean
unit ball is just
n times the volume of the euclidean unit
ball to get
our upper bound so that was really uh
nothing much it was just
uh use it the use of this uh uh
classical so to speak uh effing
isoparametric inequality
okay now for the left-hand side so it's
for the left-hand side
we have to do some work so what do we
have to do to get the left-hand side
well we'll have to find a good
k-twiddle a convex body in k for which
we can compute
this uh little effing surface area of
cape beetle to get the estimate that we
want that is to get
well k twiddle is a convex body
contained in k
this maxima effing surface area
consequently is always
bigger equal than the little effing
surface area of the kate wheeling
and we want to find arcade riddle so
that our desired estimate holds
now thinking about
that there is this effing isoparametric
inequality
a natural first candidate to think about
to take as the k
twiddle would be something related
to the euclidean unit ball or to an
ellipsoid
so um first
natural idea to pick would be maybe
if we take the sk twiddle the ellipsoid
of maximal volume
contained in k maybe that would be a
good candidate because we know from the
f and isoparametric inequality
ellipsoids or unit balls
do give us maximum affine surface area
so let's look at an example to try to
see
that uh if that works
uh so so here i have written what's the
ellipsis of maximum volume that goes
back to fritz john
it says that uh if a convex body case
given in rn
then uh there exists an ellipsoid which
i've called
e0 of maximal volume contained in k
and it's also unique so
let's look at uh the example of um
k being the l infinity unit ball
i have drawn it again here we know that
the ellipsoid of maximal volume
contained in the l infinity unit ball is
just the
standard euclidean unit ball also we
know that
uh the isotropic constant of the l
infinity unit ball is just a constant
so what we would we get if we picked as
our k twiddle to get our lower estimate
what would we get if we picked as uh
kate riddle this ellipse rate of maximal
volume which is just the euclidean
uniform well
we would get uh the following so we look
at
our maximal fine surface error divided
by the volume that's the expression that
we basically want to compute now
divided by the volume raised to the
power n minus 1 over n plus 1.
so this is bigger or equal then now we
pick the ellipsoid of maximum volume and
okay
then we'll have the volume of the euclid
of the l infinity unit ball which is 2
to the n
well now i would have to raise to the
power n minus 1 over n plus 1
but if n is large dimension is large
that's just the
modulo constant so now
we know that the affine surface area of
the euclidean unit ball
which is the one that we pick here as
our maxima
ellipsoid of maximum volume is just n
times the volume of the euclidean
uniform well we have
this divided by 2 to the n so what we'll
get
is if one computes that we'll get just a
constant
over 2 to the n times n to the power n
over 2 and that is much too small
because what we really want to get is
n to the 5 over 6 and not n to the n
over 2.
so um so this ellipsoid of maximum
volume
is not giving us the good lower estimate
so we have to do something else
so let me show you what is there
something else
that we will do
and so let's uh first uh uh
position uh the body in the convex body
that we are dealing with
let's position it uh in a in a way so
that we can uh uh
deal with it nicely what we'll do is
we'll put the body in isotropic position
so
volume is one center of gravity will be
at zero
and we will assume uh that the isotropic
constant uh
uh that is given to us like so that is
the position is like so that
our isotropic constant can be computed
as indicated here oh i should have said
uh
by these double bars i denote the
euclidean
norm on rn so now we've placed the body
in isotropic position
and what we'll do next
is i will not show the proof
in the most general or actually i'll
give an indication of the poop but i'll
give an indication of the proof
not in the most general situation but
only uh under the assumption
that the isotropic constant is indeed a
constant
then i don't have to carry this lk with
me all the time
um so uh assuming now that the isotropic
constant is a constant so that i don't
have to carry it
with me all the time what do we need to
show to show the lower bound
well the quantity that we want to bound
from below is this one here
so maximal efficient surface area of k
divided
by these expressions here but we've
already seen that
n times the volume of the euclidean unit
power raised to the power 2 over n plus
1
this is just a constant also now as we
are in isotropic position we know that
the uh volume of k
is one so basically what we'll have here
is
just modulo constant the uh maximum fine
surface area of k
and this we want to bound from below
that's what we need to show
by a constant divided by n to the 5 over
6.
um what i'll try to indicate is um
not striving for the best exponent
so instead of 5 over 6 i'll indicate
how we get to the exponent 1.
so how do we do this what we will use is
now comes this
other thing that was in the title will
use a sin shell
estimate that is due to krigora's powers
and
olivier gedon and emmanuel milman
uh what does this thin shell estimate
say
it says that there are absolute
constants
there is an absolute constant zero so
that if we
look at the volume of all those points
x in k that have euclidean norm
strictly bigger than this absolute
constant zero
times root n times isotropic constant
times t
this volume is small namely smaller
equal and e to the minus root n
times t and that for all t bigger equal
than one
okay so let's
specify things a little bit namely let's
take
um t equals one and then let's recall
that we are in the situation where we um
want to assume that the isotropic
constant is a constant
what is it that we are actually looking
at when we are looking at this thin
shell estimate
we are looking at the volume of all
those
x in k that have euclidean norm bigger
equal than another absolute constant c
twiddle times root n and we know this
volume is small so it's smaller equal
than e to the minus rooting
so if uh we draw a picture
then what it means so here is our convex
body
here is our ball with radius c twiddle
root
n and what this estimate here says that
okay the volume that is outside this
ball with radius see it little root n
but still in k and this is this red
set that i have indicated this volume is
small
that is what this estimate above says
okay on the other hand
we know um
[Music]
if we look at the volume of all those in
x of all those x in k for which the
euclidean norm
is smaller than a constant absolute
constant c
1 times root n and c 1 we will
choose appropriately so we look at this
volume that's of course trivially
smaller equal than the volume
of the whole ball with radius c 1 root n
which is c 1 root n to the n times the
volume of the ball
which is of the order c one to the n
times n to the n over two coming from
here and then comes the volume of the
ball modular constant it is also n to
the n over two
so if we choose the c one
accordingly we can make this smaller
than one eighth
so so the this volume here that is
inside the ball
with radius c one root n where the c1 is
chosen right is also
small so this says that with
the proper choices of c1 and c2
the volume that is in this annulus or in
this
thin shell around square root of two
this volume can be made large namely
bigger than
four so is
bigger equal than c1 root n and smaller
equal than c2
root and and this volume
is bigger than one-fourth this is what
we can what we can achieve
choosing the constant c1 and c2 in the
right way
okay so what we now do
to uh get our estimate from below
is that remember we still want to choose
a k
twiddle that is um doing for us the job
to get the estimate from
uh below for our maximal affine surface
area
what we will now do is we choose as the
k twiddle
k intersected we have to intersect with
k
because we want to stay inside the
convex body k
and we intersect with a ball that has
a radius r where the r is chosen
suitably within this annulus so i've
made a picture
we have um our body
okay we'll have our annulus that's given
to us by the small radius
c1 root n and by the large radius
c 2 root n so here is our annulus
and now we'll choose our
right that is we choose a radius r
so that we are placed within the annulus
and intersect with k so that is this
red uh uh the the convex body that i
have indicated in red here
so that is the k twiddle that we will
take uh
for getting the lower bound and uh
and that gives us in fact uh uh the
lower bound
um maybe i'll
maybe i should say something why one
comes up with uh
such a construction um and there are
basically two reasons
why we came up with such a construction
one was
so to speak a pragmatic reason which uh
is that and i have said that before
basically there are not so many um
convex bodies for which we can compute
the uh affine surface area for
because of the gauss curve which are
involved in the thing
it's notoriously difficult to compute
alpha and surface area and we can do it
basically only for the for the for balls
or ellipsoids or polytops
so so that was the pragmatic reason for
us
wanting to bring in uh uh
the boundary or parts of the boundary of
the euclidean ball
now the other reason is um
is as follows it's
because of this effing isoparametric
inequality we still
do want to bring in um
the euclidean ball or an ellipsoid
because this inequality tells us that
effing surface area is maximized for
euclidean balls or ellipsoids so we do
want to have that
somehow present and uh
and then if you think about what i said
is how do we get a fine surface area for
the euclidean ball
well effing surface area for the
euclidean ball
is nothing else but the usual surface
area of the euclidean ball
which is n times the volume of the
euclidean ball
so now we have a result which tells us
that
volume is concentrated or volume is
big within an ambulance so we
suspect that oh okay maybe f answer or
maybe surface area and consequently
effing surface area
will also still be big within such an
annulus
so that was the thinking why we picked
uh
this thin shell estimates and we're
hoping that it would give us a better
result
um thing is
as i try to indicate one has to be a
little bit careful
uh which radius one chooses within this
ambulance
and um in order to make things work what
we'll have to do
is we'll actually have to subdivide uh
this annulus
a into smaller sub
uh that i have uh written here so
uh we'll subdivide it in subannually l
i where i runs from zero to k
so what's k where do we stop well k is
the
how do you say floor
it's an integer floor yes it's the
biggest uh integer that's smaller than
that
integer floor i i never for the life of
me i cannot remember
i never can remember how to call this
thing yeah
it's the floor of this number here and
so it's
uh n uh log to the base two of these
constants c2 and c1 that we have
but you'll see uh uh the order because
dimension is is typically large
it's actually of the order um m so
so that's where we end with the
subdivision of our annulus
and um what
do we actually have well if i is equal
to zero
then uh we'll just end up at
because we marched through the annulus
in steps of order
maybe i should show the previous one so
we'll march through the annulus in steps
so we'll ice equal to zero we'll start
at c1 root n
and and then we march through the
annulus in
our steps of order two to the one over n
and um
so for i equals zero we'll just start at
c
one with n that is at the lower point of
our annulus and we'll go
up to c1 root n2 to the one over n
and as we march through the annulus
we'll end up
with our i being k which is this number
here
so we'll end up at c1 root n2 to the
n log base 2 c2 over c1
over n so n goes away as it's logged to
base 2
will end up here so the c1 goes away so
we'll end up exactly at the upper part
of our annulus and then we'll march a
little bit below
so this tells us that actually
a is contained in the union of this
annually
and as k is roughly n
and as the volume of a is big namely
bigger than one over four
we know that there must exist at least
one i zero so that the
volume of l i zero is bigger equal than
one over c uh times n and c
can actually be taken to be equal to
four
maybe i should go a bit slower now
because now it's the technical part
so
so okay so we are almost there
um so uh
as the k tweedle we'll put now k
intersected with the euclidean ball
where we have picked as the radius
r and i've called it r1 now um
of uh the this uh
sub annulus that corresponds to the
lower part for this
i zero so that is our r1 it's c1
2 to the i0 over n root n
that is the r that we pick and then of
course trivially k twiddle is contained
in k
and let me just show you two steps
because i'm
seeing that i'm a bit short of time
let me just give you an indication
how we now compute this uh effing
surface area of this category
so um i have written the definition
again
so affine surface area of k twiddle
so it's just the definition it's uh the
gauss curvature raised to the power one
over n plus one we integrate
with respect to the usual surface area
measuring u
and we integrate over the boundary of k
tweedle
nothing has happened here i have just
recalled how the k tweedle was defined
namely as the intersection of k with
this ball
uh with radius r1 where we have chosen
the r1 so that we are within the
analysis
um now instead of integrating over this
whole
boundary we only pick those parts
twiddle that corresponds
that correspond to uh these parts of the
ball with radius r1
that are in k so we
only perform integration over that and
there we know what the gauss curvature
is the gauss curvature is nothing else
but
um uh our one
to the minus n plus one so
uh because we know what r1 is
it's c1 2 to the i0 over n root n
and this to the minus n minus 1. so that
is our
r1 so we get
we get that this maximal effing surface
area
is bigger equal then comes
our radius which
is this but it needs to get taken to the
power one over n plus one as well
times the remaining surface area
uh that is the surface area of these
parts here
that is the surface area of k
intersected
with the surface of this this ball with
radius r1
now if you look at this quantity here
then you'll see that that's actually
because two
to the i zero over n uh that's uh
basically a constant
um so uh so what this quantity or what's
the order of magnitude of this
expression here is just
a constant over uh square root of n
now um what we'll have
here is something that we still have to
compute
but now i claim that this surface area
can be estimated from below by another
constant c twiddle
times root n and uh if we have this
claim
then uh actually our maximal fine
surface area
which is bigger equal than the fine
surface area of
k twiddle will be bigger equal than um
this first c over root n times the
middle over root and which is c
over n which i wanted to uh you know
give you as a lower estimate
uh because uh uh i didn't want to strive
for the best exponent which is five over
six
and um i guess i should i should stop
because uh yes so uh so thank you very
much
uh um i'll not go over the
other things i'll stop here
yeah thanks